it's the fighter and the kid had to run
it back cause we back at it again yeah
we gon keep it moving like it's never
gonna end when it was brendan when it
was brian when he was just talking to
friends we got the kid calling on the
left with the fighter on the right had
to do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
we're out come on baby
you got straight teeth in bed big hands
obsessed with this dude wait what's
going on with your teeth i got a little
i got i got i got some one more month of
invisalign one more month of into his
life by one more month it means another
year we've got the best look maybe the
best looking guy in comedy yeah the most
handsome guy in comedy the most handsome
looking podcast right here this is a
good looking person i mean i i mean i'm
i mean
hey i hate to say i'm an older here's
the thing like if a group of girls saw
us yeah who do you think they're gonna
be like all right who's jumping on that
old grenade you know what i'm saying
like
there are always there you go hey dana
do you mind jumping on the old here's
what happened that old lady goes out
yeah just the yeah the big girl goes
again no no no no have fun all the time
no [ __ ] [ __ ] you guys for a second
you're right but i'm going to tell you
this we're going to get a grenade we're
on a yacht we're on a yacht any
situation yeah bar i promise you there's
always that one girl who has daddy
issues that's right that just likes
she likes whole grain but you know
what's gonna [ __ ] it over what you're
invisalign
i was kind of into him but yeah he's
wearing braces
he's got everything
they don't even know about invisalign
they just think it's weird teeth did you
have braces yeah when i was a kid you
just kept them straight like that huh
yeah it was easy congrats brother yeah
if you don't know it looks like you're
wearing like one of those coveted face
shields over your teeth yeah yeah he
doesn't want his teeth to get covered
yeah yeah yeah chest just
yeah i can't i don't want that new
bearing i can't [ __ ] wait to get
these off i can't wait
you have a couple of things we're going
to answer with the grenade jumper she's
like well he wears braces and then he
also wears sandals and jeans
but also in comedy you're in the top
like one percent
of good like i see gross guys get
hooking up all the time well let me just
find funny yeah admit that when i was
younger in my 30s and 40s
those days are done well the great comes
in yeah things you get you get oh you're
the cabana boy come on yeah yeah
but i heard i heard a guy i think was
jordan peterson said you you if you're
good looking now and you're strong and
you like yourself that's cool just
please understand that there's going to
come a point that no matter what you do
you'll get uglier and weaker with every
year no matter what you do there's the
exception that there's some time piece i
don't know dude yeah i'm getting larger
with age crazy i don't know yeah it's
just weird it happens naturally yeah
it's all natural that's very weird i
don't know i don't know yet but to be
handsome in comedy that was like in
fighting like they would always say he's
smart for a fighter
yeah
there's always that like
you know 4a
for a comic for a fighter i think that's
true i think i think the two of you guys
clean up you also he does a [ __ ]
action
i lose girls with my silliness that's
the problem
just too silly all the time yes i just
want to play actually i'll tell you guys
in detroit and detroit is uh how do i
put this black
and uh there's this this girl comes up
she like she like recognizes me and all
the black chicks like i'll talk to him
whatever and they're like this corny ass
white guy you stupid right that's like
there's no attention from yeah but there
was this one chick at the bar who
thought i was uh one black girl no white
girl oh she comes over and she's nobody
she goes are you jeff diaz yeah and i'm
but i'm also like drinking a bunch and
having fun with all the people and
there's a guy named luke knoll from snl
who was in the movie and we were just
being giggly the whole night doing stuff
he spit whiskey into my mouth like a
baby bird like he was like the mama bird
and i was a big brother whiskey and we
we thought it was so funny
that i like i showed her the video i was
like hey
did i show you this and she goes yeah he
showed me that like three times and i
was like uh and then i go that's gonna
be you later and she goes what and i go
yeah with liquids and solids she goes
what i go yeah lickies are solly that's
assault brother and she goes that's
sorry lickies are solly
and i just watched her walk away and
talk to all of her friends about how
much of a loser the lickings are solid
the one like the one nobody you scared
off the ones nobody you know when you're
talking about pooing in someone's mouth
that's kind of just
insane it's like this guy's into some
weird [ __ ] yeah that was so funny
did you remember that there was a woody
allen movie this long time ago where she
his sister he's like what's wrong she's
like i went on a date i can't and he
goes well what happened
i've been so lonely and he was so nice
and we were dancing and then i let him
tie me into the bed oh no my god you
could have been killed because i know i
can't say it i can't because what
happened how bad could it be i can't
because he goes well what did he do
because he got over me and
he went to the bathroom oh jody allen
goes oh god
yeah i mean too much people are into
some weird [ __ ] i think she thought i
was some weird freak that's what she
thought you wanted to do but i was just
being silly and thought it was like
hilarious to be absurd well you'll find
someone who likes that you'll find
someone who likes that but also
anybody who's into having i'm trying to
be positive yeah yeah it's never really
into that i didn't really want to do it
no you was trying to be sad she think it
was funny yeah she did it i said that my
friend goes he sticks you know he goes
you don't stick your finger your tongue
in a girl's ass and i go
i'm not in the into the air and he goes
out you get [ __ ] on your dick or the
tongue so what you [ __ ] and i was like
well i i'm just not we're hanging out
joey
i know i'm like all right let's not get
carried away the thing about being in
detroit though if there's a black girl
who likes white guys
i'm the man i'm the guy yeah you're the
guy they're not into it no
maybe just the bar is your hand yeah i
think i just turned downtown detroit the
whole time did you run into barry
sanders no that'd been great
does he live there
uh or does he hate detroit i forget i
don't know i was in a limo i was barely
saying this and i was young yeah at a
super bowl party and i just kept asking
him questions and then finally he just
pulled i just hear him go like he must
have had a sign to the driver yeah it
just pulls around on the side can you
guys get out
is that yeah not to get a taxi no yeah
he's like yeah no doubt there's a lot of
lions questions music can you just get
out here is he too many lying questions
can you get out yeah we got out on the
side of the highway wow that's all
later nerds i kind of get it though
now i was like oh god that's one thing
i've learned about
they don't want me to come up and go oh
you know i was at vandy when you throw
the they don't they just want they
they're gonna come back when you're a
chick i thought i'd get tired of the
chicks yeah do you know chicks or do you
have a private jet no yeah like we i
can't use you dude the clip you sent me
about mugsy bugs yeah like muggy bugs
thought i'm in the nba i'm gonna get so
many girls no they get guys like us
coming up to them going oh you were the
best dude you should have that's it yeah
it did yeah that's right that's right
that's exactly right you get bromance oh
he's in uh wichita kansas that's what it
says oh wow he just walked away at the
height of his career what was that you
think uh was he getting cte did he feel
the the lines were absolutely terrible
like the magic and still is like the
worst managed team of all time i heard a
great story about it but i don't think
like calvin johnson also retired i had
the you know the best receiver one of
the best figures ever he just went we're
just never i'm sick of losing they
wouldn't trade me i was like i'm out and
he made it he was like and i saw some
money made a lot of money he's like i'm
just sick of losing we're not going
anywhere i'm out
i heard a story but i'm not sure it's
true that barry sanders like called to
say i'm thinking about retiring and that
like cell phone service was bad so the
guy was just like oh he said he's gonna
retire and so barry sanders just went
with it that's what i heard i don't know
if that's true or not no that's a bad
look for verizon
horizon is the reason barry sanders
retired yeah he started the conversation
i just got this new car phone these guys
are pretty cool yeah
that's not to do with cricket wireless
he was calling from vonage
not a flip phone
i don't know if it's true or not but
it's uh
who could validate probably not true it
might be true probably him
i just read it on uh one of these dumb
sports things yeah it's like that young
kid i mean granted he's from that area
he played at michigan his dad played at
michigan he's the number one pick in the
draft this year he had drafted by
detroit and so is detroit and
jacksonville it's like when you go
that's like yeah you're in the nfl
you're making money but you're literally
he's happy
you're on the worst team of all time you
and you guys are never going and dominic
so was on that on that team for a while
yeah i remember he stomped out a bunch
of guys
huge so strong is he still on there he
got it
what do you want a super ball for the
rant that's right uh
yeah temp super ball baby
but the uh
so that guy that just got drafted the
lions
haha davis is this very funny talented
comedian out of detroit and um he was
dming with him the same night he got
uh drafted by detroit dude's super happy
to be here i was like he's excited
he goes yeah dude he's like one of the
hometown boys yeah well i think he's
from there but i know he's like a real
like he he he's a home table his dad
played at michigan played in the nfl so
maybe they bounced around but yeah maybe
it was the second one then there was
like one guy that's from there
right the the white boy he's playing
the dn that's what i'm thinking that's
what that's from the one i'm talking
about that was dm davis is like a very
like hood guy oh guys he's like so
excited to come to detroit and huh
because you're gonna love it here he got
a cornerback or something yeah he's like
a skinny fast guy yeah yeah
excuse me pascal skinny fast guy yeah
that'd be such a i mean it's tough right
like you drafted my viewers team they've
i wouldn't want to ever been good and
you're like
all right number one pick yeah put the
hat so let me ask you this part about
the draft when you get drafted in the
third round fourth round that doesn't
necessarily mean you're gonna be on the
third fourth round it does it does if
you're drafting the
sixth round okay how many rounds are
there six
so
third round you're that you're putting
some money yeah i mean you got to earn
your spot but but you have to play for
the worst team that's always the worst
part yeah like you you don't want to be
the best guy in the draft you want to be
like the 10th or 11th yeah then you're
going to like you know pretty solid team
yeah and everyone's stealers you want to
be number one i can read the i can hear
the comments already
of course you want to be the number one
who's going to be the number one
driver yeah i know it's best to be
number one but you're right because now
i got to go to the cavaliers and just
get dunked on by all the good teams or i
have to go to the seattle mariners yeah
you're trying to figure it out by
yourself i'd rather go to a loaded team
yeah also in a cool town like the third
round all of a sudden i'm playing with
tom brady you know catching passes from
the greatest of all time that'd be way
better like you're around that yeah
detroit like everybody's a loser yeah
everybody unfortunately that's just true
yeah what did they lose every game one
year yeah well that's the owners
apparently the owners are terrible they
they you lit
a lot of people say the way they're
managed and the owners are just oh it
starts yeah from top to down that's why
the owners are just the worst and then
they're really bad at drafting and it's
like
it's just not good
i don't want it to be that bad until the
owners die yeah forever
but i'm pretty sure the owners come for
it who are the owners the the lions
pretty sure some european guys i thought
they had something to do with the the
ford family i thought the some like
slick looking guy because i just looked
this up i was like why doesn't dan
gilbert own the lions
yeah there is see ford
see uh descendant above ford and
firestone the pistons the guy that owns
that i was looking up or are you
thinking of jackson jackson has that
like cheap guy oh yeah he's cool though
yeah i like that guy no but i was
looking up why doesn't dan gilbert own
the pistons instead of the cavs because
he's like this big detroit guy and then
i looked it up on some slick guy she saw
a lady owns it huh yeah does she get any
[ __ ] for being so bad she must get so
much hate uh she's not on social media
you know when you're bet dude if you're
a billionaire would you eat like if i'm
elon musk granted he's like the more
famous guy but dude if i'm healed
this would be one i'll be one instagram
picture would be this oh just know it'd
be a picture of my dick that's it just
every monday you should get a big pick
of my dick and i get banned and i come
back once i'm on board that's it another
pick of my dick cause i have a billion
dollars and i don't care that's right
like i was telling jay like when i was
in the thick of you know all my hate
with all that [ __ ] i know how do guys
like that people like genuinely hate
like like uh ted cruz yeah or like uh
tucker carlson who gets all the hate
jay's like have you seen tucker carson's
last post i'm like no it's some book
they wrote on him but just like it's
literally a novel of just spewing the
worst thing ever done he took a picture
with his like number one best seller
like he just
he's all the way in because he has his
fan base who rides or dies
it's a very there's no middle ground on
tucker yeah yeah but jay's like general
of that team yeah my brother goes read
uh he goes go to any ted cruz uh tweet
god especially read the comments
especially now how does he deal with
that congressman who's like [ __ ] you ted
cruz like you're a congressman i told
jacob how they deal with these they just
don't they don't give a [ __ ] they don't
pay anything i guess it's part of they
just keep going yeah i've never seen a
congressman tweet [ __ ] you ted cruz
you're useless and it's like jesus
christ you guys trying to politicize
this thing and the guy goes hey [ __ ] you
man there's a bunch of kids are an
[ __ ] yeah i got a good argument yeah
yeah just shut the [ __ ] up or have it
hard to debate that one
[ __ ] you
[ __ ] you and he did [ __ ] you again or
something there's like a double he
doubled down on it was the rest of like
the congress like hey hey man
no not safe no bring up bring up the
tweets it was this [ __ ] had to do
with the school shooting yeah and tag
checkers like a long thing we shouldn't
be politicizing tragedy you know to make
gun control
and then this
you know
there's whatever the argument is it is
it is but but there might be a timing
issue here and the guy goes
um
i mean
so ted cruz tweeted about it or no
somebody tweeted at him the congressman
had tweeted hit him
other than his reuben uh gallagher yeah
pearl's uh
expletives at ted cruz after yeah yeah
that's the guy that's the guy that's the
guy go go to that it's hilarious he goes
okay
yeah he goes
oh yeah [ __ ] you ted cruz just be clear
get slaughtered just get your ass to
can't go and you're useless then he goes
just to be clear [ __ ] you ted cruz you
[ __ ] baby killer neighbors that's a
that's a pretty crazy comeback yeah i
feel like i'd probably ban that guy
i call the guy a baby killer i'll at
least restrict him you know yeah on
social media banned him a week yeah i
think that's fair emotions are running
high man the highest yeah yeah and it's
i get it yeah i mean
yeah yeah anyway
but yeah i don't want to get into it
i've been depressed about all the things
i dropped my son off at school today and
walked the param and i got out of this i
got a 10 and then talked to security
guards i got a i got a fourth grader so
yeah
increased security today anyway my thing
is my thing is anytime this the podcast
is recess speaking of which those
[ __ ] chuck taylors are wait hold on
they're lit no thanks buddy dude those
are off the chains thanks pal is that
cool to say yeah i've had them for quite
some time some
off-white chuck taylor's there you go
this has to be the
cheapest shoe that china makes
might cost them three cents yeah yeah i
mean there's not my this is this is like
a t-shirt yeah you're gonna pay somebody
you can pay some money for them right
not those jokes people
yeah a piece of money these two guys are
expensive yeah these are found a way to
get a cheap shoe expensive well yeah it
shows you how stupid i am jeff you went
to uh you went to shoes no i tried it
for a second i'm out he's into this you
into uh his teeth in here yeah i like uh
jeeps and stuff yeah
drugs bro hit
his car should be the mascot for the uh
january 6 capital riot if there's a logo
it should be his car if he saw it he
parked that then probably rather night
it's just like it's a monster truck oh
it is outside yeah if they told donald
trump hey create a uh jeep it would be
this oh for sure it's republican as [ __ ]
yes oh dude and the horn
black lives matter protest dude there's
a horn on it it screams redneck the horn
is so intense if you go to jeffy's jeep
you can find it oh it has its own uh
profile it's on
instagram jeeps jeffy's yeah jj
y
jeffy's jeeps
there it is oh my god jeff dice jeeps
yeah it's uh it's pretty big i got that
green cherokee and then that big red the
big red well you know what you just got
to be ready to off-road in case you find
yourself having an off-road it's like
wearing cleats all day
it's everyone just looks at me they go
why okay i don't know it's cool right
the other thing you wear
you wear jordans you don't go around
playing basketball all day so you're on
the highway with no you don't have any
air conditioning you're just oh you're
just dizzy taking in all those fumes all
day who needs air conditioning you don't
even have a [ __ ] see those cameras
you don't have a door uh no i got uh i
got doors for it but that's not
convenient huh look at the boat yes
gator no that's ostrich that's awesome
that's all that [ __ ] is so america that
picture i love my country that that
thing will go over anything yeah i
didn't it's the best and uh yeah with
the doors on top and all that what is
that you live in northern hollywood
got to go hard yeah you ever use that
winch in the front you ever use that
once never once
because i got four wheel lockers and i
got all this stuff like i don't really
need it dude the horn the one [ __ ]
horn one time i tried to use it those
are all the bumpers i've ever had the
one time i tried to use the wedge it
didn't work and i was like god damn it
this is embarrassing yeah but just
pulling me out with like one of those
little uh
i don't even know what those things are
called and when you're looks like a
caterpillar a cat no um a gator you know
those gators yeah oh yeah yeah he pulled
me out of that i was like this is
humiliating my buddy my buddy
it's a golf cart on steroids yeah and
she was like and he pulled me out my
buddy does he he's a diver and he
retrieves bodies so like if there's a
body oh they said no in fact he was in
fort meade going to get cool gig he
would find all his bodies yeah crazy
[ __ ] right like he was diving in
terrible they found oh terrible they
found a [ __ ] they found a brand new
tacoma in the water like brand new right
in lake mead and what you look for then
is a dead body sure but it was actually
stolen insurance games oh that's right
you get all that stuff
would you rather have that job or do
wednesday through sunday at the laugh
factory in las vegas oh definitely
i could find a tacoma with some dead
bodies in it
but he said he said basically he said
they call him gear queers you'll get a
guy who's not experienced in
in
diving but they've got all the gear they
got a shitload and they do these deaths
they hide boys they'll go like this
they'll be like just drive around and
they're like this is gonna something's
gonna happen
and and all inevitably the guys with all
the gear just end up [ __ ] [ __ ] up
down there and you got to save their
life
you know you know that when if you
inhale so here you go get one of the
guys every time it's always the guys
with all the gear it's like this guy's
not experienced he's got way too much
[ __ ] on something's gonna go wrong boom
and you know you're the guy but here's
what's really interesting about that
when you inhale you have to figure out
where the story's headed caleb when you
inhale salt water well i was gonna tell
you when you inhale salt water you gotta
go to the doctor right away yeah right
you have to go to the hospital
immediately so if you if you have if you
have almost a drowning right you gotta
go to the doctor at the hospital
immediately because you will you will
dry drown and it's it's because the salt
water mixes with like the
the membrane in your lungs and your foam
will come out of all your orifices and
you just [ __ ] die right and same
total guy comes on guy comes on
guy comes out he's got all this gear yep
all this gear
and he had a knife he had like a you
know he's got a knife here he's got all
the [ __ ] and all the guys who are like
these are the guys who retrieve bodies
they've got just their you know you get
whatever they're gonna get some guy goes
like this guy he goes um
uh you had a lot of experience yeah yeah
a lot of experience but i was gonna be a
seal but i decided you know this makes
sense oh yeah and
we had to keep an eye on that guy and
literally the first dive they're trying
to find a body hump
yep brought him up jesus and uh and
he literally
almost died he just inherited and he's
just i wish he would have said he died
for the day if stories pay off on this
you could pull up
are you allowed to still go in the
carpool lane with that like if you're
just driving around [ __ ] what are the
rules i don't know
cops like yeah i couldn't help but
notice you're the only person in here
you want to check the back you want to
check the trunk that toyota tacoma
you'll find before you make judgment
find a little foamy face guy if you want
to see him you'll find old spongebob in
the back oh spongebob that should count
that's two you'll see patrick in the
trunk
you guys know that movie total recall
that happened to me once
i don't know jeff yeah the whole thing
really jeff
all right oh you know what i got into
last night is uh that series it's from
the documentary the staircase yeah you
remember that
yeah that guy something peter said
lawyer well that's one of the theories
i'm going to see what you thought
so so you know so what happened she fell
down the stairs hold on he said she fell
down the stairs so the cops come there
and and on the phone call he's frantic
right so the cops come there yeah they
look at there's blood everywhere all
over the staircase like the fact there's
no like head contusions that would equal
rolling down the stairs yeah and they
look into it and she had like 64 like
hit wounds it looks like someone hit her
on the head all like all over her body
well so yeah and she's like no she just
fell and hit all this that's what he
said he goes no she was drinking she
took valium and then fell down the
stairs they looked more into it
he
he was married when they had like six
kids because she had kids outside the
marriage here you know from previous
majors so they come together they have
six kids total right
so
uh the kids are a little older but then
this is what they think happened
so he was having uh gay sex with
somebody outside and yeah
he had a bunch of
like emails and uh with a male
prostitute and all this stuff and she
found this out and they got in a fight
he beat her to death freaked out he gets
charged and convicted of murder of
murder sure
then gets out because the evidence they
found with the blood that they messed
with the evidence that only showed that
he was responsible for it they didn't
look at all the evidence so he gets he
posts bail
he goes then he has to go back to prison
but they retrial it back but he's so
he's broke at this point it's like the
first case he's stupid first case took
like 600 grand he no he's not stupid
rich well he was trying to figure out he
was at the beginning but he was drinking
wine
during the
lawyers took all the lords took all his
money he was a writer though right he
was a writer and sold a big script to
hollywood for a 500 grand front but you
know you're not like scrooge mcduck
so then actually
yeah there you go
you started yeah she had three tests
anyways um but
uh he actually pleaded guilty to murder
for uh beating his wife to death
but he did it uh he did it yeah he
eventually did but but he was set free
because if you say this i forget what
type of murder uh guilty charge it is
but you agree that you uh
committed the the to get out yeah but
you plea bargain you plea bargain but
you also acknowledge that the evidence
shows that you're responsible for it but
you don't admit to that evidence it's a
weird yeah it sucks i'll admit that i
did it but you have to let me out for my
honesty yeah basically it's like this
weird plea bargain deal i won't do it
again but but here's where it gets nice
so i was watching so on the series i'm
watching so i remember the old the
actual documentary i looked more into it
this work it's dicey either he's the
most unlucky person on the face of that
or you're going to bring it up or he's
murdering people i know we're going to
be in germany he had a friend
a really good friend who also died the
exact same weight then he took their two
kids that was 10 years prior so that
lady who died in germany
once uh she saw that uh his wife died
the exact same way she called the
detective like yo man this is too much
of convenience because
coincidence because my uh sister died
the exact same way look into it so they
looked into her death exact same thing
yeah no she didn't die by accident
flawless she was also beaten to death so
again he's either the most unlucky
person on the face of the earth or he
did
the biggest theory is the owl uh theory
so
well so they're saying why because she
was frolicking in the attic for some
reason where they live in north carolina
durham north carolina there are there's
a certain type of owls spotted great
hornets that's kind of aggressive yeah
and they're saying that the
marks on her skull and all this stuff
would appear to be and like on her arms
and the scrapes would appear to be from
an owl also in her hand they found owl
feathers and then the other hand they
found like uh pine needles from a tree
jesus so so it but they but the his
prosecution said or his defense said
that theory is so extreme it's very well
that could happen but if we bring that
up it's so extreme it's good he's going
to look even more guilty it's so dumb
it's it's okay but i remember that
documentary they showed the the first
girl that fell down the stairs his
roommate yes and then they talk about
that a second girl and i go listen
if that's a coincidence i don't believe
in a god that would let that happen to a
man twice
what i'm saying like if i'm a judge i go
all right we let him off the hook for
this once
another stair falling you know like i
was just like we gotta lock this guy up
even if he didn't do it he was also
right that's what it is it's a pattern
if you have a pattern in that behavior
i say the life even if it's a
coincidence
so it's going to happen again there's no
way i can believe that this is more
creative about how you kill people dumb
dumb
you're pretty creative though because
you got to wait twice every but how's
every woman you know so bad at stairs
yeah is he still in jail are you guys
he's free now and on uh netflix i didn't
know this because i was like why
staircase on netflix with each wheel
show because the director came out with
three new episodes to add to watch
documentary it's an update what he's
doing now where he's living i'm shocked
that he admitted to that though like i
thought it was like a huge he got away
with it i thought
uh yes and no you know he admitted to it
but under the
impression that he actually beat his
wife to death how much time did he do
oh i mean eight years the first time he
did eight years then finally they found
that they [ __ ] with evidence so they
put them on parole until they looked
more into it they went back to trial
yeah then then pleaded guilty then got
out then they think he went back again
like it's so so he he basically has done
a lot of time
he said i did do it just to get out they
said
it's it's just i forget what they call
it plea bargain right no no it's not
plea bargain it's a certain uh admitting
to guilt
but it doesn't mean that you actually
did the crime but you're admitting to it
it's so weird yeah i just found about it
last night yeah
that is a here here's and this might not
be a popular take and
can i really this committed to the idea
so you maybe can
steer me in a direction
i don't think you should be able to get
away with things because of some weird
legal technicalities alfred please right
that's alfred plead so a guilty plea
entered as a part of the plea bargain uh
by a criminal defendant who did not
commend the crime or who does not
actually admit his guilt
wow
maybe accept as long as there is
evidence that the defendant is actually
i never knew that even existed me
neither that's okay i read last night
like what the [ __ ] that's so weird
alfred please
the al horford plea
is if you believe that someone
intentionally tried to fail yeah and you
just say i'll
yeah
that guy's life's just screwed oh yeah
well if you if you murder talk to oj if
you murder society tends to go you know
you killed a woman that you were married
to you're gay
and maybe just marry a man no brian he
was innocent
yeah i believe that that man was found
innocent yeah in a court of mind his son
it might have been the topic oh you mean
aoj all he's guilty of is uh you know
being having a good time guilty of
running the ball he's a good guy yeah we
we jump to conclusions on that one
you're right buddy you know what's funny
they said oh dna in the in the oj book
they said when after he uh was found not
guilty he went to his favorite
restaurant where he they gave him a
table every time he went and the owner
was like oh no no you can't sit here
anymore this isn't for you he's like
what because there's another place that
will him sit down he thought it was all
good because he was found not guilty by
a jury he thought that meant everyone's
on board with him no and all his
couldn't nobody would call him anymore
his friends family nobody nah man that's
that's what happened no here's what i
was going to say earlier is that like
and maybe you guys will disagree but
it's like i don't like that someone
should be found innocent on like
technicality like i got a buddy who's
just got a dui he totally did it
but then he got an attorney who's our
other friend's wife and um they got a
bunch of stuff wrong on the ticket like
the year of his car
and like the this like his address isn't
correct you know and all this different
stuff and they're like they're like so
we might be able to get him out of it
it's like what just because they didn't
get the color of your car right you
didn't drink and drive you idiot it
happens all the time but that's such a
stupid guys get out of prison for murder
for the same that's crazy have you ever
had a friend that you defended and then
you find out like three years later
somebody goes oh yeah now he [ __ ] uh he
[ __ ] over my friend and a couple other
people and you go oh
dude you know sometimes you can
you gotta it's it's hard man some people
have a track record that doesn't come
out for a long time yeah it is well but
it's like also like i don't like what
happened to me recently like if i was
shoplifting or something from like a a
place and we were like best buddies we
both worked at like a hardware store
yeah i'm just stealing [ __ ] yeah i don't
tell you about it i just want to be your
friend right i'm ashamed of my stealing
but i just do it and then you come to
work and i'm not there and the boss
comes over they go hey what's up man you
go where's jeff and they go oh he he was
stealing we had to determine him you
would then you're inspired
he wouldn't do that yeah i was like well
you wouldn't know what i wouldn't yes
so that's what that kind of happened to
me two days ago yeah yeah i've known
somebody a long time and
and they were going through some [ __ ]
and then i remember they had a thing
with somebody
and randomly i was
having dinner with somebody i don't even
know that well and they said uh
they go yeah he [ __ ] my friend over
yeah and i went who's your friend they
said the name and i knew you were like
barry
i love bear but he got a different he
got a different [ __ ]
i got a different story then i hear it
from random somebody and then i also
this guy's also had other issues yeah
it's tough so now you go it's like
there's a staircase
yeah there's a pattern and i'm like am i
on the wrong team have i been defending
the wrong guy here yeah
[ __ ] man i don't know hey how much uh i
should try this whiskey your teeth
there's a wine glass you tried to put it
in this wiener-shaped bottle i don't
know why they bought bottles like that i
have no clue why i might you try the
tiger thick is that what you're talking
about you want the tiger thing yeah what
do you guys want what do you recommend i
wouldn't smoke you that one you gotta
get the tiger thick dude definitely do
the tiger thing
definitely
um don't get the text mother guys yeah
tell me who wants some i'll have
something
three glasses do you want some little
pull four glasses with uh who wants you
ice or no uh other little ice yeah four
glasses with uh the the cool cubes that
haven't eaten anything yet but a little
whiskey sometimes you don't need food no
dude come on food's overrated
what are you a new alcoholic
attraction get your calories from
liquids draco i wasn't paying for it
drank
an embarrassing humble bread
oh yeah
my friend goes i don't collect this wine
you can have it i was like but that
one's has anyone ever called you an
alcoholic
no i i don't drink much uh i had an
ex-girlfriend call me alcoholic once it
triggered me for like a [ __ ] month
you might i think what i drank with you
all the time have fun yeah we had a
great time we made love on beach like
what are you talking about
because i know an alcoholic when i see
you i didn't drink for like a month and
a half like that [ __ ] that i got a great
try to prove it to her
you you probably drink every day right
with her
drink it to her every day just have fun
endemic you're playing and i loved her
yeah i became an alcoholic doing panda
there was nothing else to do exactly so
i was just straight up and then
in a fit of in anger she called me an
alcoholic and it rattled me like it'll
trigger you yeah you know why i
triggered you
you know why because you're not calling
me yeah
but i'm really not like i actually went
to yeah no doubt i went to like a
therapist and i went to like a guy that
my buddy's been like clean for 20 years
you got 20 coins you know
thanks
is your thing whiskey what do you drink
yeah i love whiskey and beer i just like
i like the social part of drinking yeah
but i just when she said it i was like
this is insane like made me tailspin and
they were like you're definitely not an
alcoholic yeah can i ask you something
this is for everyone so i define it can
you stop
when you start
yeah
the answer is no
i was just bored of it i don't want to
like because i never get drunk yeah but
like yesterday i'm getting this thing
chris and theo want to have an
intervention because i drink at 10 a.m
when we do the show they want to have
yeah but it was like gross 5 30. that's
what i said i got 18 million that's what
i said that's i i go what time do you
guys wake up to me i'm halfway through
the [ __ ] day i've been up since five
yeah
fun
man
i don't i've never seen i've never seen
you i said that never actually actually
never seen on the road have you ever
seen me ever no i don't even yeah i've
never seen you never and to me you've
seen me drunk the one weekend i went to
nashville with you oh that's right that
was a good time you were like hey i'm
gonna head back to the and i was like
where's everyone going oh hey come over
here it was like two in the morning yeah
all right when you put it away though
can you can you find a lot of whiskey
yeah that's fine yeah yeah was that one
guy that was there uh jelly roll jelly
roll just keep that guy he's not he's
tre he was bringing tequila's like this
big jelly comes in there i'm not i'm not
even there's 30 shots of vodka jelly
there's eight of us yeah there's not
even physical before he goes i don't
know and just hand them to random people
yeah it was at soho house yeah that's
right now nashville is so hilarious he
just keeps bringing him around and i go
i thought i had a problem that guy's
gotta get his problem he's the best
sometimes people wanna chemistry i can
handle it i can't i'm a [ __ ] if i drink
one glass of whiskey i'm good and the
next day better watch out because i
might be a little off my kill you know
i'm a [ __ ]
dude i'm i'm not i do not have a couple
things i'm not good at one i'm terrible
in the cold i become a coward i'm going
to complain two i can't drink a lot of
whiskey
speaking of which that's way too much
whiskey for me but i appreciate it the
ice is pushing up a lot of it
it's a buoyancy issue thanks buddy
you're right that one to mark
hey thanks for bringing me whiskey
that's a nice thing that friends do for
each other that's right
cheers buddy love you man thanks for
having me thank you mark jeff has been
done cheers
cheers buddy
now jeff has been in detroit shooting a
movie you've kind of just been mia mike
young 35 days
it's too long too long to be in one
place dude that's too long to be in
hawaii
dude 35 days too long to be in fiji i
was losing i'm saying like 30 100
i don't want to be in [ __ ] anywhere
for 35 days ever i like being home for i
go i got to get out of here oh dude yeah
14-day man i get that being on set
the death of fun it really is you're
just waiting around you know everyone on
that movie i bet if you bring anyone in
here from that movie makeup department
producers p whoever they go that guy's
crazy because i would just talk and make
jokes or play like catch in the in the
hallway i was like so bored all the time
me too yeah yeah at least you have a
captive audience to make people laugh
right that's all i ever did on set ever
with no exception with no exceptions
until i went i went you know i've never
been on set where i didn't want it to be
over now imagine going from project to
pride like that's your life that's why
actors are so weird they have to do that
all the time it's like johnny depp
they're like oh you believe this guy's
in like [ __ ] tahiti just like passed
out with mascara on scarves and
necklaces
like yeah dude he had to play jack
sparrow for nine years he's losing his
[ __ ] yeah yeah you're not a bad guy
you've got to be drunk and high all the
time sorry use edward scissorhands you
[ __ ] you think he wants to do this
and he had to deal with amber hurt and
he's but he's making 80 million dollars
of yeah i mean i just remember we'd rap
and i'd be like i guess i'd go back to
my
con i know nobody in detroit except the
people on the movie so i would just be
like hey come drink with me and they're
like all right i guess this guy like i i
wouldn't do that if we were at home like
if we were shooting in l.a i could just
go to my place and go check out my
buddies yeah but like when you're in
detroit alone it's just too long yeah
it's about detroit i mean yeah why
detroit uh because that's where mike
young's from dan gilbert is funding the
most of the movie who's dan gilbert dan
gabriel owns the cavs but he owns like
everything in detroit stockx i don't
know that little caesars mike mike's
great man how's the movie did he write
it it was fun yeah he wrote it it was
tough because i played mike young i
don't know if you know that i didn't he
wrote himself as the lead so like
there'll be lines like yo man that's
just how this goes you know and i'm like
i don't think i would say it like that
like i don't really talk like that yeah
no like yeah you're playing i'm not like
the toughest guy who would wear like a
uh chain and detroit you know he's like
that's your good guy he's the best bring
up mike young what's he look like
he's awesome great
yeah he's funny great comic but he's one
open forum
you don't meet other mike youngs so if
i'm playing mike i'm like i don't know
how to really do it he used to open for
sagitt man yeah he's awesome and and
mike is mac is mike is not ambitious
either mike is one of those guys who
just wants everybody to have a good time
he's not gonna he's not looking like his
mother his mother was like yeah but his
mother was like you know
i want him to buy a house or a condo and
he just doesn't give a [ __ ] he's yeah
he's cool he's not materialistic
he's not ambitious
and that's the guy's referencing earlier
from detroit who was uh dm and all these
athletes
oh ha ha davis yeah dave's a very funny
guy super monster he's like the new
kevin hart
really yeah yeah mike's great man mike's
just a great guy it was hard look at you
in that picture yeah dude i'm feeling
good i think in that photo i'm holding a
whiskey actually
that exact head shot there you go i got
a whiskey in my hand you got a smooth
forehead you were young then
so you went you went from detroit to
hawaii okay you went detroit to hawaii
yeah hawaii's the best we got to get you
out there yeah yep yep dude they were
not for 35 days but yeah no no
four days most for stand up you mean i
went there for listen i stayed there for
mr room i did it for like 10 days i was
i only only had one show i had one show
friday but i told my guys like dude i
just want to see maui see what it's like
and he took me to all he's local but he
was saying character i dressed like crap
the whole time because that's the only
way you fit in yeah yeah i just had to
wear like swim trunks and like a dirty
t-shirt and everyone's like he must be
from here yeah he lives here yeah you
don't be an outcast you don't want to
wear chelsea boots when you're in new
york the skinny jeans chelsea yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm pretty
stick out actually one night a girl came
up to me and she's like
she was like flirting with me and i
wasn't interested in anything but i'm
bored so i'm just talking to her and
she's like by the way don't wear this oh
that's rude
don't wear this yeah it wouldn't be dumb
wearing it right now
what am i supposed to do i can't go home
and change the [ __ ] thing to say
you were discussing earlier the uh some
of the rituals in hawaii that were
surprising to me
what i mean like music like uh
oh yeah yeah
no not one time with the hopper yeah
what you're talking about yeah you said
you didn't want to let this on here
that's the mower
you know when a fight's going down you
hear it because they i don't know the
term for they they get uh they get hyped
up so it's like it's not like a like
some guy be like say something or like
you know something
say something you know you can't wait
dude in hawaii it's like sup [ __ ]
head kicks come on your way something it
was like you go oh [ __ ]
that would scare me if i'm wrong
hawaiian's big people yeah oh yeah they
do tongans
like i think it's tongans like we had to
get the guy in the cu football team and
you know see you with a lot of hawaiians
because we're taunting one of the
coaches uh mike cabral was he grew up in
hawaii so he'd recruit a lot of
hawaiians dude they're the nicest people
on the [ __ ] planet then when they
drink it's jekyll and hyde dude they
drink they want to fight nicest people
here you should meet the ones i met
they're culture they're sweethearts but
yeah and uh when you're on their island
and they're going hey what's this guy up
to is he looking at my girlfriend your
two hands better be built like brendan
too if you want to if you want i want no
problem that was the only thing i
thought about is that so he was in
philly and i go what are you doing we're
texting back and forth and i say you got
to come to hawaii because you'll draw
great out there yeah and then you'd have
so much fun and it's also like you can
just go on the beach and chill you don't
have to go to like sounds great you have
to go to these local bars you can just
have a good time we poured vodka in a
water bottle we had a great day whatever
my point is then i start telling other
guys like chino and trish and uh willie
about having you out there and they're
like
well he's he's he's big right yeah and
they go he's like an ultimate fighter
yeah he was now he's a funny comedian
and they're like
yeah people are going to try to fight
him i go what yeah man they'll kill them
and yeah i know but that's just their
mentality yeah like i want to get a go
in here yeah it's good
but they they'd get [ __ ] up
but that's that you don't want to do
that nothing's going to happen i don't
want to do anything no i'm just going to
hide so so i would tell the story before
i like the story i personally love this
story because it was when i
like you know you hang with your friend
and you don't think you know he's my
buddy right but he's and we [ __ ] around
i'll grab him and stuff but you know but
he's checking you've been grabbing me in
a while i'm gonna grab you i'm gonna
grab you i actually thought about it
someone's tested your might i'll test it
i might test them later but we don't we
don't know but a friendly test i mean
not like you know oh yeah yeah i mean
you started wrestling where i'm like
we're not doing head punches which is
you know no i probably went chin and the
short kings we did that thing yeah
even though you're being like that stuff
how'd you do he threw me like a ragdoll
yeah because he's big all of them versus
dude
no it's also technique but so he so
there's a black belt but chin people
think i messed up your neck no
the neck thing came like weeks after
shin's face
you messed up his neck dude we talked
about this came from the two guys
no so i beat them i won that war against
a little not really yeah i did
no remember they shook you up and
carried you out they couldn't get me out
remember we broke the light here oh no
they picked up chappelle yeah sure i was
able to survive i i won that one that's
right that's why josh pitting
chappelle's used to
i know dude they picked him up like
nothing too like oh yeah they should
just got himself to go up on his toes
yeah and they picked him up and charged
him right
hips if you don't have heavy hips
but brennan brennan so we're we're all
rolling and i was rolling with the group
people nothing big and then there was a
samoan there who was a black belt in jiu
jitsu and a professional fighter but
like a samoan so whenever you think
samoan what do you think you would think
about 260 even the ladies 265 they like
their guitars small and their women huge
yes yes
and gay in my experience
guitar small they're women here people
huge women well he came from a tradition
of smoking
big titties what would you say i got
right about 250 to 60 yeah yeah
bald head and and so we're we're like
moana
brendan's being gentle with everybody
because it's just so much bigger right
and there are a lot of black belts and
stuff but ben is kind of like whatever
letting you get a position not a big
deal he's not going to try to [ __ ]
steamroll anybody yeah and so um what
happens is uh all of a sudden we're
walking we're done and you the simone
guy goes shop
oh no
and brendan goes brennan goes i go
well i go what the [ __ ] that guy's a
black belt and he's samoan and i gotta
run i go holy [ __ ] man
are you gonna be right he goes he goes
yeah i am because
watch this oh nice and i i watched him
take that out of me dude he took this
and
[ __ ] did what he does to me i was
like
oh there are levels to the game so you
know if you're going to get in if you're
going to if you're going to try to
tussle with them you're going to have
your you will get your neck broke if you
if you get crazy and the winner and the
winner got a spam sandwich with that guy
i'm talking about it
yeah
yeah the winner gets banned that's it
you get nothing you get nothing yeah but
but i'm saying if you're going to be in
a bar and you want to go i want to see
if i can beat up brandon but i have
witnessed it before something happens
like so when people see me going to a
bar they might want to there might be a
moment where they go i'll punch that
idiot that girl my girlfriend is looking
at him or something
i'll be able to talk my way out of it
i've done it millions of times
hey man notice reggae come on she's
pretty of course everyone's looking at
it relax you know you talk your way yeah
well play with the gifts god gave us
right
but
i have witnessed a strong guy see
another strong guy and god
for no reason drunk my friend randy
valeria one of the coolest funniest
nicest dudes i know he'll get some
whiskey in him do you know todd duffy i
know todd really yeah todd is in his
speech he came like new pals right like
he just came to my house we drank todd
yeah
we had a good time he's a freak and i
said let's go to this other bar so now
it's like me and 20 of the people that
were in my house huge yeah much bigger
than me oh you've seen his face the
guy's like just all muscle yeah so we go
to the uh he's got muscles in his face
his ears have muscles and very well
trained and so we go to this bar called
the woodman right by my house and it's
all 20 people that were in my house my
new friend todd and we're all hanging
out and my buddy randy just decides out
of nowhere like to go up to todd and go
hey don't think just because you do that
ufc [ __ ] that i couldn't take you oh
wow and i go oh no that's uh that's a
guy's not been punched in your face
randy picked the one guy
with the [ __ ] will kill everyone yes
but he hasn't been with a professional
so what will happen with randy is
randy'll get grabbed he'll get gripped
just gripped and it'll be a whole
different world for him he'll go oh [ __ ]
yeah i don't think here's the thing i
know randy could destroy i mean he looks
like martin's jack but also i don't know
if randy's ever fought a pro so like he
hasn't learned that no i'll tell you
exactly how it would go it would go real
bad for him real quick
me and mark and jay and david went to uh
the bar stool bar in philly because
shane gillis like you got to come here
so i'd go up there it's me and shane
we're talking we're surrounded it's like
all these guys and they're dancing and i
was like i don't know what to do with my
hands man you guys just get a drink like
good idea something like this and he's
like man
isn't it where everybody's looking like
what are you like do you think they want
to fight no no what all these frat guys
i don't know i'm not worried man no i
just don't want to be here i hate music
i hate people in general i just want to
go home
i only came to talk to you man nothing
gives me more anxiety than being like
hey we're all going to dance you're like
oh god
told me a story a long time ago where a
guy was [ __ ] with his friend
and he he said hey maybe you should you
know nate he's like hey maybe you should
stop doing that you know and the guy was
this big lumberjack and the guy goes guy
goes
[ __ ] you or something like that and he
goes well i'll [ __ ] with you or
something and apparently nate i said
what did you do and it goes well i kind
of just grabbed him i grabbed him and i
i knew he was going to try to hit me so
i grabbed i stopped him and i i grabbed
his head and i i just went
and he brought his head down
he brought us he went
shut up
and the guy went
out and then he came back too and he's
like you [ __ ] ass
shut up and did it again oh my god and
just that was it and i go to nate i go
were you nervous and he goes he didn't
mean to but he goes no no nate's the
best like
professor wait so here's the thing you
fought professional after fighting
professionally did you ever have any
like fights outside i've never been like
in a street fight never ever
i put myself in that environment boxing
is another example like just having been
gotten in the ring with certain people
it i don't think people realize what
happens to you when you get hit once by
somebody who really knows how to hit so
you you can say that you're tough and
say you think this is another
development that a lot of people know
how to professionally do this yeah but
that's in the last 20 years but but i
think i think what it gives though
everyone was an amateur
what gives them even more validation is
these youtubers come over into boxing
now and they're like see see
yeah they're doing it no
well just like like ufc's became a thing
mixed martial arts has become a thing
these like regular guys who just work at
the bar
have they every day go to some octagon
and learn from guys like you had like
that that didn't used to be a thing
everyone's just a bunch of pedestrians
street fighting and the odds that you'd
meet a professional well my buddy's a
lawyer who said millions my mother's a
lawyer said that he goes i represent a
lot of people who get in fights and they
because they train the injuries are way
worse now way more way like [ __ ]
crazy [ __ ] you guys don't know what to
do i never dealt with this now you're
dealing with real real injuries like
really dangerous stuff i think that
comes from the anxiety in society people
want to learn to defend themselves 100
percent it's also going to be cool yeah
you have more access than ever now if
you think it's cool you know some guy's
going to teach me i got 40 bucks a day
are you we well so i used to live in
this house there's like 11 dudes who
went to university of washington just me
there's 12 guys just living in a house
no that movie fight club was real
popular so we started like a fight club
although we told everybody
we told everybody about the fight the
first rule was tell everybody everyone
cause we thought it was so cool yeah and
also it's like it's fun to fight your
friends because like no one's gonna get
too carried away hopefully not yeah i
mean it did happen but like it wasn't
like in a outside of a bar yeah people
like stomping
so anyways i climbed at the ranks pretty
quick the the two biggest guys
in the house was like a firefighter
named justin morgan who's literally like
i don't know how much older than me he's
a senior in college and i just i'm like
17. and then the other guy was a
firefighter named ross but then the rest
of those guys so the the top two would
beat the [ __ ] out of me so badly that i
would go to work and i'd be like
coughing up blood like because they
would do a lot of kidney shots yeah
would you have gloves on or what would
you no let's fight club yeah just fight
club but we wouldn't we we would punch
in the face pretty often but it wasn't
like mostly like your body like yeah
crazy [ __ ] if you try to tap try to get
someone with you all right it's over you
punch me in the face
that sucks yeah
um you're gonna go to work
and i would i'd have to go to work my
boss would pull me like hey is
everything okay and i'm like no i'm in a
fight club he's like oh jesus like he's
doing this on purpose here's my problem
with all of this whole story why are two
grown fire fighters living with all
these young kids no no because they make
enough money to live on their own no my
parents kicked me out of my head no
because you guys are good-looking
they have a pretty good salary where
they could get their own places well i
think they were the early part of being
a firefighter where you just have to go
for free there were pledges they're
volunteering like they were going to be
firefighters and they had to like go
stay at the firehouse oh gotcha yeah
because they were only like seniors in
college everyone else in the house was
to see was uh going to college
i got kicked in my parents house and
they let me live in this house that's
nice yeah but they were like they were
nice to me they were like big brothers
but they were like
you know they would still be like yeah
we got to beat the [ __ ] yeah they whoop
drastically oh it's also nightly
fights with them i'd call the firehouse
leave some like really aggressive
voicemail be like i heard you got that
little pussy-ass
gay guy ross working there and he's not
a gay guy and he they didn't like that
in 2001 you know
he couldn't talk like that then and so
they like really
you couldn't say that stuff right now
yeah now it's hotter than that ross
comes home and he's over my i slept on a
futon he's like over the futon the hell
was that
someone's playing basketball
so he's like friend ross is here come on
no ross would be over my futon and he
had like an alarm clock he just cracks
it on my head i'm like oh no because i
know that i left that voice yeah and he
goes trying to embarrass me in front of
the fire department huh you trying to
embarrass me in front of my friends i'm
trying to work trying to gain the thing
and trying to and then i just knew i was
going to get the beating in my life like
right there but you enjoyed it well
here's the thing i did here's the thing
getting beat up
teaches you how to fight i got beat up
so mercifully by the top two that i
learned how to beat up the rest of the
guys in the house you're a third in
command you learn how to cover up in
this and i would keep your eyes open
yeah i was the youngest and these guys
like morton would come in he's like i'll
challenge diddy that's what they call me
diddy and i was like all right i had i
beat him up so badly diddy then i
started crying you know like something
in me broke like i just liked her
you know they did a study on that like
kids who grew up with bigger brothers a
lot of the like the toughest football
players fighters like uh certain boxers
grew up with mostly brothers and
what's really interesting is that i
think the fastest people in the world um
grew up at like the fifth
son in a family fourth son of the family
and so all the kids were faster and they
had to keep up with their oh yeah isn't
that weird
yeah well eli is
the youngest right eli manning yeah he
was the youngest yeah he was the best
quarterback in that family i don't know
about that you know you don't mean that
you guys are wrong you're looking
forward you guys are looking for a
debate here yeah yeah he's not better
that's just being honest yeah you can
use super bowls against the patriots
yeah sure manning that he won peyton
only won one super bowl that other one
the defense won
i mean yeah you know they say payton had
one you know the super bowl you know
they say that the middle brother
who
got injured no there's that that's the
oldest the oldest the oldest they say is
the most gifted yeah you know that now
the the the son of
the oldest he's the number one recruit
in like 30 years what's great revenge
what's this exactly what this guy got
nothing
genetic things alabama
everyone's trying to get him to come to
school every single he has a high school
kid right now he's a high school senior
monster because he grew up with eli and
his uncle's eli and payton so he learned
how to watch tape coop he's a monster
oh he looks like both superman he has
his own sean espn too hold on
let's see the sun i want to see this kid
do manning sun yeah yeah
i don't know if it's cooper man it might
be wow archman
what a cool name archer manning that
good who's hyde who has the same picture
as the lot of manning's man a lot of
mannings that seems confusing um hide it
looks like exactly the old line recruits
call me crazy but hi manny looks a lot
like peyton manning
boy i'll tell you what so you grow up i
guess watching tape and all that stuff
playing all the sports oh and your dad
and your two two uncles are mvps yeah
nfl come from crazy stock i mean hyde
manning
there he is he's muscular enough yeah
arch manning archband he's the number
one recruit in like 30 years they said
what he's just a freak oh good that
makes me happy that'll be cool for
cooper you have any six four at uh 18
years old he's just a ball oh jesus
yeah they have no idea how terrible
would that be if you're archman and
you're throwing out you're just slinging
touchdowns and they go hey your last
name's manny are you related to peyton
manning and he and he's like no no my
dad is cooper manny they go i don't know
yeah i mean eli
no that's my grandpa who the [ __ ]
cooper man who the [ __ ] is he's just the
dark one what are you talking about the
[ __ ] one in the family the peanut
butter flour no no no no no
cooper's my dad god damn it never heard
of cooper manning
that's tough dude i know because didn't
cooper get injured he was supposed to be
really yeah he was supposed to be a
monster and just got injured but
apparently he was the most
talented one what genetics matter but of
course you would say that because we
have no idea well no also like this
these things happen
spinal stenosis there you go
pinched nerves ended his playing career
but apparently he was like the most
talented manning wow
the whole family man i mean jesus christ
these things happen though it's like
it's kind of like you if if cooper's
really good at football of course eli
and peyton will be also yeah because
he's he's so good he's playing with them
yeah but i think when your dad's art she
met you well that's archie
so all your fundamentals are just
drilled in they're honest yeah
malcolm gladwell book that talks about
this but it's like a hockey player i
don't remember what it was it might be
it might be outliers yeah but it's like
those kind of things just happen you
know it's where it's like
all the pro wrestlers now had dads that
were pro wrestling yeah because if i
told my parents i want to be a pro
wrestler they'd go what mozart's dad was
mean they go shut up like a famous music
teacher so that makes sense
bill gates is like in this unique
position where he was in seattle
the person's dad was his programmer to
give him access to code when nobody so
you get this giant head start on
something right yeah you know
but no one even knew he's getting a head
start it's just like this perfect right
that's an analogy for sports two years
ago yeah hockey all the kids were born
in these months because it gives you a
six month advantage when you're five
right well think about it like uh like
with major league baseball right now
there's like i don't know i'm gonna make
up a number but something like 50 major
league baseball players currently whose
dads were like really good players in
the 90s yeah so it's like craig biggio
jr and like raul modesty's kids ryan
julio frank's kid uh
beau bashette is dante bechet's son
vladimir guerrero jr c sophia uh yeah
prince fielder i don't think i think he
retired but the same thing it's the same
thing they're all
his dad yeah they're all
because
you know have you ever thought about
what made you a comic like oh for sure
what do you think it was well what's
your therapist say
what i can tell you i mean it was so my
parents never like abused me or anything
my parents were like normal people but
i'm like a victim of like neglect like
they never cared about anything they
were never around they never listened
what were they doing nothing they just
they didn't want kids i think so like i
was the kid that would like be like i
draw something and go look at this and
they go
and i go hey look at me i'm dancing on
the counter and i go [ __ ] i'd get into
trouble i would just try to i was always
interested
no i had two sisters yeah but they like
i was always trying to be seen or being
heard or being goofy or being like hey
let's be friends with your sis your
sisters took care of you they were great
yeah yeah they were awesome yeah but
they did the same thing they were all
kind of like
trying to get attention yeah trying to
get some sort of attention i believe
the biggest
uh like it's it's a it makes great it
makes comedians but also it's like
you know you want your parents to pay
attention you want them to like listen
to you you know mitzi sure used to say
should they the story i don't know if
it's true but i've heard it from a
couple other people when polly short be
crying in the crib she would just let
him cry
and and they'd be like he's crying and
she'd be like i'm teaching him how to
bomb and keep going oh that's kind of
funny
terrible
terrible parenting yeah that's all for
me like for me growing up
every moving every year and a half two
years
and and being thrown into a whole new
world country new continent
i had to get people to learn a lot of
animal facts yeah yeah yeah you're doing
a lot of weird animal impressions
hey you want to see what a cobra looks
like when it's muscular
hey guys
you guys ever seen a penguin i remember
i remember saying to me i want to talk
about owls i was like don't be the last
guy picked on the team be good be
somewhat good at sports get coordinated
and [ __ ] be an idiot yeah get him to
like you you know that's why i was
always making goofs in class it's like
oh this is great it's like where i'm
getting attention everyone's paying
attention to me yeah yeah yeah man
i think that's that's like almost like a
human intelligence what about you what
do you think what what made you want it
yeah
yeah you were you were
forced into sports it was almost like
maybe because it was so serious my way
to deal with how serious and stressful
it was is to be the funny guy you know
like it was so intense everywhere yeah
like in locker rooms
all locker rooms are so important are
they though aren't they i thought they
were all but it's also like football
players tend to be have a high social iq
because they're they're always [ __ ]
with each other and they're friends yeah
it's like you not really it's more of a
it's like initiating that's not true am
i wrong about that yeah
that's hazing it's a big difference so
the older guys always hates in the
youngest yeah when i look back at it
it's like this guy was like like shoving
me into the [ __ ] wall like when i'm a
freshman because he's a senior yeah
i'm getting physical abuse by like my
first i've never played football before
this is just part of it yeah it's like i
that doesn't sound like you know
productive at all i just want to quit
now yeah yeah
yeah my shoulder's bruised
but that's how it's like it's like there
is it's more of a haze what about family
stuff anything with family or no
um
i don't want to get into it yeah i don't
want to get into it you told me a couple
stories yeah that's that's nice what do
you got chinese
my mom was tyler
share the stories but i was saying like
those couples were like oh that makes
sense
but i mean
everybody i know is your mom's great i
love her it's it's it it's interesting
that everybody i know who fought or who
does comedy
it's almost like you have to have some
dysfunction in your past well i think
that with every human ever yeah seinfeld
says that i'm sure there's a lot of
bread truck drivers with trauma sure but
no one ever wants to go i bet all bread
truck drivers have yeah it is weird like
in comedy like oh everyone's dark like
no they're not oh yeah you just know
some dumb they just happen to be dark
comics
i know a lot of comics that are not dark
i'm not dark i'm i don't think of myself
as dark no
let me have your spots you know yeah you
have rewards i got my awards deep
callbacks but also until like
here's my perspective on meeting
comedians i'm always like
mostly really smart people and observant
and i think intelligence correlates with
darkness you know i mean they're certain
or even being an outcast or whatever it
looks like being aware of those certain
circumstances yeah because the reality
is dark you know that's how that's if
you're observing it
but i don't think comics are the
smartest people in the world in the
fashion that not intelligently smarter
not book smart not any iq things but
just like that we can see something
terrible and go this is a lot for my
heart and my brain to deal with yeah
i'm gonna if i make light of it i just
make a joke me and my buddies can deal
with it creating irony is another thing
like oh you know i'm not i'm not saying
this isn't important but it's like i'm
gonna have to go about my day yeah if i
make a joke about this well think about
think about even like the old testament
adam and eve right don't don't bite the
apple from the tree of
what will you lose your innocence when
you get what
tree of knowledge
like if knowledge is what [ __ ] give
it that's as old as [ __ ] that's 3500
years old yeah like the more you know
it's hard not to be a little dark it's
yeah it's hard not the more you know you
just are aware of ignorance
there are a lot of snakes out there yeah
you know there are a lot there's a lot
of danger out there yeah yeah i gotta
like be silly about it it's gonna help
me not [ __ ] freak out i think i'm not
gonna spiral if i can just make me make
a joke or goof around a little bit i do
that when i get stressed and worried
about the world i start writing comedy
well my sister at her funeral i was
making all these jokes and goofing
around and my friends were like not my
friends but like the people that came to
the funeral were like that guy goofing
around over there like that's the
brother like she was like his mom so
like that's just how he deals with him
of course and so like that's i mean i
was depressed as anybody in that room
but i was like this is just roasting
yourself
well i was like no the eulogy was good
but like but in the room god i haven't
seen you in a while like you know just
being silly and yeah that's what the
buzz energy
well or it is i mean like my my
celebration
for you yeah my buddy his his friend the
kid was 16 that had an overdose in the
house and then um it was terrible but
they they're sitting in the front rows
the two brothers the sister and mom and
and that and the uncle that nobody sees
yeah he never sees he's [ __ ] he was a
plumber and he just he he found a tie in
his tie he had a clip on time that was
this [ __ ] so maybe yeah and he leaned
over god
ty's here
and literally in the front row and the
brother goes he goes did you see us
yeah and they start laughing but people
think they're crying because their ears
are written but they're like we can't be
laughing this is outrageous
and they were laughing the whole family
was laughing they needed that life they
needed it yeah that laugh was madison
don't show up with a micro tie yeah
laughter is the best medicine you're
going to find something to laugh at my
condolences on account of your brothers
dude
that's actually my problem with most of
twitter different goes around with all
this serious [ __ ] it's like we need some
soft stuff that's what comics are there
for yeah whenever everyone did it can't
be serious all day all the time with
this stuff it's too much everybody's
life is serious [ __ ] off i think with
funerals too like my grandma passed away
then my uncle was really close i didn't
go to any of them i don't want to see
him like that oh really yeah i'd rather
say i'd rather remember him that like
the the way my memory
that's healthy that's a fast like
healthy i had really good experiences
with them i'm not gonna say that where
they're dead cold it's just weird and
[ __ ] sad environment like i don't
want to see that my friend gives like a
speech like you barely knew her yeah
yeah it's like i don't want to be there
dude
my friend's mom yeah yeah
you ever been to a black you made me
laugh once yeah you ever been to a black
funeral i haven't brian you're loaded
you just asked that and you know any
jokes went through my head that i'm like
oh great i'll get canceled set me up
like that my buddy my buddy's mom died
what were you doing
my when my buddy i went to high school
because there's a gig in the night yeah
yeah one of my closest friends
corporate games daryl daryl's mom dies
it was in harlem i go to harlem i go to
harlem and i've never been to a black
church i'm just like i was all ready to
be sad right it shouldn't be the first
thing the deacon says is he goes i'm the
only white guy there for miles and the
first things he can say goes now i
believe her name was ida may he goes now
adame wasn't a sad person now and
everybody's like nah everybody's like
and he goes so so this is a celebration
of a life not a morning of a life this
is a celebration well they sang
the whole [ __ ] time and everybody was
an amazing singer i i was literally like
this is a [ __ ] party it was the
craziest thing the weird white guy that
brought a [ __ ] rabbit snake like
right i bite them in the neck
let me tell you if i ever die right you
guys have to go to my funeral you guys
go to my funeral i just want everyone to
be sad be very very sad yeah no i want
you for weeks un-inconsolable yes that's
what i want my feeling i want everyone
to be like we'll never hang out or have
fun again now that dies dead yeah and
happiness is not just
everyone just kill themselves with my
funeral like that's what i want my my
father what his best friend's funeral
everybody's good at making these sad
speeches my dad right there just goes
like this
he goes he goes
jesus christ he goes this is so annoying
these [ __ ] people are like and
everything's over i'm so sad he got so
mad he got up and he just went he just
did a whole [ __ ] celebration of my
mother's
and he was making people laugh yeah
i gave a really good nice eulogy i don't
remember what i said i wrote it all down
obviously it's been a while it's been a
few years and the uh it was funny that
this one lady after i think she's like
shaking all my family's hand and she
goes you're the that was the funniest
and best eulogy i've ever heard also
i've never heard someone say the f word
in a huge boy
feels so casual
oh yeah i'm a comic listen my [ __ ]
sister was the best you know i [ __ ]
love her man did you have trouble not
crying through it or you just did the
whole thing i had a little frog in my
throat but i uh yeah i plowed through
yeah
wow
wow dark yeah
but it was still like funny i was like
i'm gonna get some laughs yeah you gotta
get some laughs i'm gonna try this new
material
yeah
[Applause]
my other sister she was like she was
like don't come up to me and say i'm
sorry for your loss and i was like
that's just people being nice
so she was like lecturing but like she
bombed the eulogy
for me i'm way more likely to cry to
wedding than i am a funeral i'll cry
weddings i [ __ ] i was at a wedding
this weekend best week and my [ __ ]
father-in-law gets up and and starts
talking about his daughter and starts
crying and i was like i'm [ __ ] i
don't know anybody at the wedding and
i'm like [ __ ] wiping tears
no i'm sorry crying i'm gay i know i
don't think i've ever cried enough at a
wedding now my brothers i did but then
your brothers if i first of all if i
don't know them
unless you're giving out gold bars
unless you're giving out gold rolex so
i'm not coming it was very embarrassing
by the way because i didn't know the guy
i didn't know any i knew well you
shouldn't be either right you shouldn't
be there well my girl yeah good friends
with i know the one i know the couple
you want yeah yeah yeah
yeah it was a malibu it was a great
wedding actually but mostly chicago
people i didn't know
and i'm like up there and i'm the guy
and i'm dude i'm and he starts telling
me he's trying to keep it together i'm
thinking about my daughter
really did she get maddie like stop
crying my girl makes fun of me yeah
she'll stop crying i watched the tyson
documentary because that's not these
people and it was an old one i started
crying he was talking about his mother
how his mother died of cancer i started
crying that's tough yeah
that's not a wedding though
so steven tyler
let me pee let me let's go
brendan i i live hard because i am hard
dude i tell you we're gonna get hard
shopping you're gonna be
this weekend dude i'm glad i'm glad you
asked because one of the things about
florida and the air is it keeps my bones
sticking it's good for older people
that's why older people go down that's
why i'm going to west palm beach improv
friday saturday and doing a show sunday
dude let the fan base know why there's
no show monday it's not because of the
daddy here oh i'll be traveling and then
we'll do a show on tuesday and then i go
to richmond virginia the funny bone
friday saturday june 3rd 4th then i got
omaha nebraska funny bone june 10 and
11. can't stop won't stop dude no nor
should you dude i'm not gonna stop
either because the summer is a coming
and there's nothing better i like than
touring during the summer baby
i'm in portland june 9th through the
11th san francisco june 17th through the
18th at the cobbs san diego laugh
factory downtown san diego july 21st to
the 23rd then i got some east coast
dates for your ass uh august 4th through
the 6th is baltimore boston september
29th through october 1st get your
tickets at thinkboy.com or fatkz.com new
thick boy merch drops tomorrow at 9am on
thickboy.com
this shirt in black white and then also
the yellow summer hoodie get you some
i'll tell you what you need to get
though b what buddy i need supplements
i got i need my i need to be optimized
when i i'm on stage
i know dude and i've for years we've
been ride or die
i need we're going to get a good credit
kriller do and i keep talking creatine i
need good creatine good krill oil i can
get your creatine krill oil i'm your guy
i need something for gut health dude and
i got the best on the market i'm talking
about on it on it.com slash fighter 10
off everything that we're going to tell
you about right now on it.com 10 off we
got krill oil joint oil protein powders
protein bars warrior bars
work out stuff your brain dude we got
streaming fitness for your thick ass on
on it in 30 on demand workouts home
fitness battle ropes sandbags club maces
steel mazes quad maces primo bells
kettlebells all of it on it.com fighter
10 off but no i like misleading people
because like cap jokes are easy like
there's a lot of memes about characters
so i'm always posting about that and
people think i'm actually who's got
small legs brock lesnar does it yes
visually at least i mean maybe they're
really strong because they're like quads
but his calves are really small
his calves are like tiny yeah i remember
like watching him when he was in ufc and
i was like those are not the
have like when you see white dudes or
gigantic cavs you're like is that fun to
put jeans on
you don't you don't need huge cat he's
got uh yeah for how big he is [ __ ] yeah
he's yeah i mean for out giant i've seen
him in person that's the first thing i
thought does he not have much of a tail
piece
flat out he's all chest dude i don't
think anybody wrong soda has a thick ass
just that he doesn't have the best all
right just go to kernerville he's pretty
big doesn't it [ __ ]
oh maybe i'm wrong i just remember
seeing it
all right what do you got the greatest
thing i've ever seen in my life
here we go yeah all right
um
i'm gonna read it off yours okay so
stephen tyler claims that he you spent
six million dollars in his lifetime on
cocaine in 1975 when the aerosmith
singer was 27 he shacked up with a 16
year old groupie oops
that's how we're starting
how the [ __ ] back in the 70s people just
did they were like normal oh it says
1995 when though smith singer was 20 70
shacked with his 16 it was the 70s it
wasn't statutory
it was a groovy happening no here's the
bad person all this he convinced the
girl's mother to sign over guardianship
to him yeah hey let me take care of the
gross yeah um team became pregnant look
i was enticed by the headline of this i
didn't know i was gonna go to his whole
biography about this i spent six million
dollars on coach yeah so i decided that
like that fascinated my imagination
because you think about the things how
much coke that is first of all and then
what else you could have done with that
money but mathematically though what
does that work out to
yeah we'd have to what is
a lot of money you'd have to account for
the adjusting price of cocaine over
there
you paid for it or you did it
with six million worth hold on uh the
two broke out in 1967 but it'd be six
more years before tyler went to rehab
for his addictions the first of the last
nine times the singer has tried to get
clean
he recently voluntarily checked himself
in rehab once again still doing it that
is impressive
in his 2004 autobiography does the noise
in my head bother you
tell her right tyler writes he be an
abusing substance at age 16.
he was so into drugs he set his alarm
clock at 4 a.m to drop acid fall back
asleep and then be tripping two hours
later we started his day wow commitment
dude this is like this makes johnny jump
look like a boy scout decide to enjoy
each other as you whip out a needle and
you try shooting coke as you're getting
blown and some beautiful girl and her
girlfriend decided to enjoy each other
as they whip out a needle and you try
shooting coke as you're getting blown
the guys lived quite the life man
yeah
look at that private jet made out of
wood he's in that's how old it is
it's a wood plane still one of the
greats though how about oh yeah keep
going how about that what else is on
there dude uh
i kept things funny around the band crew
would spell each other's person's name
and chop up blow then sniff it that
sounds fun
um wait he had a he had a daughter with
liv tyler
no dude no dude come on
fuel fuel
jesus christ i'll tell you what's fun
tyler told the guardian finding the
right stewardess and turning her upside
down in the back of the plane this guy's
a savage yeah
how come no one's cancelling this guy
yeah what are you gonna cancel rockstar
for being awesome take his house away
i mean look at him he's such a galley
guy she's pretty yeah he was a real
gender fluid fella too wasn't he
look at that i mean there you go yeah
wow what an interesting looking keep
going strange looking guy
john belushi tell me what you call being
a cab without your life started when the
driver asked what they wanted to go blue
shot back cocaine the two found studio
54.
um
he was in so he was so uh addicted to
blow that he couldn't even get himself
straight to sing the star-spangled
banner for two on four red sox game
he's from boston i didn't know that
we got highs
i know the words were melting like a
candle wax against the blue sky wow
i i don't know how the [ __ ] you survived
that [ __ ] his heart must be like dude he
used to shoot heroin into his ass damn
bro
you don't hear about that a lot people
shooting cocaine like that i really like
cocaine taking it to the next level huh
yeah
[ __ ] dude how do you do it
steven tyler sings national anthem is
that they didn't say the red sox i know
that's here
no no no no no no no no
regular scene we want the
i think that's it 2004. that's got to be
it bro it's not so bad right now
yeah
is he nailing the words i don't know the
words yeah
the piece of [ __ ]
okay you can stop it jen
i was hoping for a complete [ __ ] show
yeah well i'm glad we did it maybe
that's not it he can kill it that same
year though
he messed it up in the article or did it
say that he was like i think that he's
just high as [ __ ] yeah yeah i thought
they made it sound like he was he said
the words were melting like a candle you
can tell he's high if he's on lsd have
you ever seen those videos of people
doing like stuff on lsd versus drunk
sure haven't
that's where they're you're remarkable
that's him messing it up i don't want to
see that that kills me oh here we go
that's what we're looking for
i've
lois
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
is that johnny dell
it's ridiculous
[Applause]
have you seen the uh the one where the
little girl sings the national anthem
she forgets the words and the whole
stadium starts turning on her and then
the coach for the basketball team walks
over to her and helps her yeah i've seen
that everyone's like teary-eyed in the
place like that that's what we should
have done yeah if someone screws up we
should help them yeah you [ __ ]
[ __ ] all right what else he didn't
really screw up so yeah he didn't eat
that much poor little girl i know
there's an update on dwayne haskins to
the coach
the
the football player that walked into the
freeway the highway so he had uh
ketamine in his system and like two he
blew two times for the alcohol thing one
a two point a point two o and then one
point two four chambers not one point
but one was one that was another one
point two four is like over
you know
i think .08 is the legal limit in
california
yeah
uh his system
so what happened he walked out into the
and he got hit by uh they said a dump
truck terrible yeah
yeah
all right we've all saw this
viral video by house oh yeah this is
awesome oh you haven't let's watch this
first let's put it on you're going to
love this this is brendan langley
yeah he's a former nfl player
he's a bronco oh the nfl broncos watch
this he's in cfl right now or maybe he's
retired all right let's check it out
i'll tell you what's great
[Music]
oh well that guy hit him first right yep
yep
the flight attendant hit him first yep
at least in this video
boy he's like oh look at him oh he's
down yeah he goes he wants more
oh
that's where i saw the video start yeah
same here so never mind oh
oh
[Music]
and he gets up and he the guy comes back
for more yeah and he goes he wants more
is this the toughest guy in the world
because he wants more oh my god look at
this guy
i saw this video started a different
point when i first watched it well but
still the the united employees still
started the physical contact first on
the video that's what we have there's no
like eyewitness reports that i read but
it seems like you did start start the at
the beginning of that again just to see
well there's a longer video there's
actually a longer video i want to see i
think so brian i think this is the long
video so you see that yes you see the
employee hit him first like this like
push him in the face it's right in the
beginning
let's see it's right in the beginning
that's when that guy comes back he's
like come on look look look right
oh yeah he hits him first and then he
slaps him
god he got [ __ ] up
that is crazy
actually his head movement was pretty
good
but then this goes south boom boom
he keeps coming out i said oh now i have
to slap okay here we go keeps coming out
of them you never see
i didn't see it oh yeah let me see it
again yeah those last two are punched
there's one stop that the employee the
original there's a slot and then he
slapped him back yeah he slapped him
back
where his head falls back like that yeah
[Music]
the guy slapped him so maybe i was
looking at that when brent tried norm
the assailant followed and harassed
brendan calling him
uh there had to be more this is his
lawyer saying all right oh this is his
lawyer yeah but from
that guy was here's the problem and play
stupid games win stupid prizes
like there has to be some repercussions
like he got fired you got [ __ ] up dude
you got fired but then you lost your job
brandon langley was arrested for a
little while but they let him go he's
also got a hell of a headache that's
quite a punishment oh that you can also
keep sports fans
you know like
you think you can talk smack to nfl
player whatever like this like you suck
it's like do i i'm six feet from you
right now i would love to know what
happened i bet it was something about
his flight you know as a guy
argument about the flight it was
frustrating and he got all poppy
hey man you're gonna get poppy and then
they kind of went back and forth that's
exactly what i think i guarantee that
happened yeah they do i was trying to
get on the set was he was like didn't
you play in the nfl you [ __ ] suck
dude i don't think that happens
that's why you got cut you're looking at
it united
i played seven years in the film bro
book my [ __ ]
first
flight ticket
you're working at united we're in a vast
world probably didn't even know that guy
played in the nfl it was just a mouthy
guy yep they both melted off to each
other and they had an idea yeah yeah
that's what happened
yeah
about i mean also
you're working again you're in your
uniform and you're going to go fight
some guys
so
inappropriate
louisiana
that was him
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah no i was yeah i
had a quarterback and a starting
quarterback so i'm kind of athletic did
the guy make his flight or what did he
get arrested he got arrested dude you
got arrested right there yeah yeah but
the other guy got fired i think i fired
you as he showed you can't be fine like
that at work they can't fight people
yeah dude
this isn't taco bell yeah
yeah this isn't chick-fil-a bro you
can't punch
did you guys see this coming canoe
oliver is in gennady golovkin three it's
confirmed
now that uh canelo lost i thought you
have to do an immediate rematch
but he lost and isaac all right i'll
entertain it let's do it
i thought he was going to re-fight this
other guy that's what i thought too is
an immediate rematch i think he wants to
i think let's not do that yeah is canelo
done is it over no
i don't know it's tough that guy he
fought was amazing yeah you guys are
very tough yeah we'll be triple g yeah
well we'll see sure he's older yeah
you should still in his prime yeah i
would say prime he's just you know it's
tough how old is he i don't know if
you've seen this yet brendan
when you don't see this it's a bummer
he's placed on administrative leave from
his high school job he's been i think
since 2000 been a while yeah so i appare
that's what i've heard i don't know what
[ __ ] tmz said before you go into
that's what i heard two kids came up to
him playing go hey man we want to uh box
each other and marco's cool get some
boxing gloves and box each other what he
didn't know is those kids were like hey
man we hate each other we want to fight
let us fight give us boxing gloves they
fought earlier i heard and they wanted
to fight as with boxing gloves or they
had you know gotten an altercation
earlier but they wanted to fight so it
was junior's like hold on you guys have
an issue put on boxing gloves and let's
settle it according to munoz he didn't
know that was the case he was just like
what you said that's what i heard
but either way i think that's still fine
right i do everything is still fine
all the time yeah he got back to the
parents and then you know one of the
parents complained no they didn't fire
just administrative leave we'll see what
happens yeah i don't think he's done
like it
that's the weirdest thing about sports
to me it's like we created sports maybe
i don't know we created sports to be
like kids don't fight get along learn
simulated warfare
also one of the sports is fighting
right
that seems unusual great it's my
favorite sport
you've told me mark just dedicates his
whole life to [ __ ] oh
dude one of the best people on earth
he's such a kind guy instead of getting
to a street fight he's he's there to
watch there's probably like okay
in a fight at school i mean i'm not
saying he's not that's not this yeah but
i'm saying if let's say this was the
case if he's like hey instead of
fighting in the classroom let's do it in
a a place where we can control it it's
safe here's the base here's 16 ounces
your 16 ounce gloves do that and then go
then be friends hug hug each other and
go on that's right no one's gonna get
hurt your coach or your teammate both
yeah
wrestling right yep both
great guy
all right um don't like kids fight
though you know
this is just for brennan pretty much
this is the new nike drop from travis
scott
don't these look a lot like the ones i
got oh no they put those
a little bit
they put that they look a lot backwards
just different color yeah i would say
a little bit nicer
yeah travis scott the nikolai was always
backwards so the use was come out months
ago and then obviously at the issue at
astro world where people died so he's
done it i was told they were going to
stop all
collabs with travis scott but it's cool
they're dropping them now yeah
all right just a couple more this is
just vin diesel you know he just posted
yeah stuff on instagram
so oh no
yeah i'll play this for you
for my five weeks i've been saying did
they land yet
did they land yet
don't they know i'm in london
don't they know they have to come up to
see daddy
i'm grateful
that
now everyone's together
and
that's all that matters to me
you're the best
one
so basically you know the whole fast
family you know you made her say this
right
like oh we're all back together with the
whole fast family so she's i have
something to say
we're all back together is that how he
normally behaves he's so weird what's
the best part about it yeah he's the
best follower he's highest he's out of
his mind he's got a post he's so weird
look who's back
but just his face
that was it that's the entire post so uh
what what what is the uh
so everybody's together again
dad's going to make this video right
halfway through once you go hey i have
something to say see i'm just glad the
family's back together that was so
cringey i know he's making the fight
about it yeah so uh is the rock in it no
absolutely not did he try getting the
rock he's like the family's not complete
without you and rex like [ __ ] off i'm
doing jumanji seven yeah and i don't
want to play
i heard he's crazy yeah yeah it's pretty
obvious wow yeah so this one's just i'm
just going to show you this pollyanna
vienna she's a ufc fighter she fought
over the weekend she lost but i just saw
this press conference and it just looks
pretty crazy
let's check it out
all right we're starting straight that's
how she showed up to the first
conference harry is starting strong
she's very attractive will this girl
fight she fights she lost though she's
single to be fair too that's also a
venom thing yeah yeah that's also a
venom uh issued ufc uh top
yeah
well thank you so we
[Music]
you can buy that if you want to all the
nerds at that press conference like uh i
have a question she's [ __ ] gorgeous
but she didn't get a mark on her face
and she lost this is before the fight oh
i got you yeah i just thought i'd show
you guys she's gorgeous i'm glad you
showed us
what's her ranking cool yeah what's her
number
that's her name yeah
what's her instagram where does she live
there you go yeah jeffy she's going to
be in that yeah pollyanna paulie haviana
she likes she's like guys that have
never been a fight in their lives
she's actually going to she seems like
she likes tough guys i would say good i
don't know it's always absolutely good
or maybe maybe she'll defend you there
you go we go to bargain shut up my girl
kill you yeah walking down a dark alley
she's all good behind me i'm worried
about it
she doesn't need strong she's strong
she's strong we'll just get you that's
pretty much it
there's one more if you guys want more
it's the only route to the ufc i mean
there are exceptions of course but for
the most part it was tough right no no
no the majority don't come from yeah
i was watching this earlier so this uh
only fans creator not a creator of of
only fans but she's on only fans she
said she had to sleep with people that
worked at meta
you know facebook and instagram to get
her she know she slept with them to get
on their good side no they weren't like
we'll give your account back to you she
wanted that though she
came on to them in hopes to get her yes
but that's why she hooked up with him
yeah well why is she complaining about
it she's not complaining she's just
saying that she's snitching on him
a few times she's she's giving giving
girls free game sounds like let's see
what she says it's pretty long though
too oh this is my boy adam22 yep
she looks a lot different there doesn't
she
instagram taken down
like three or four times
and the first time that i got my
instagram down or that i got it shut
down um i
one of my friends he works at instagram
he's a guy friend and so i started
sleeping with him to have him get my
instagram back
and fair yeah i like your friend like
the friend behind her like this
yeah and then i
i [ __ ] up my bag i did because i i
[ __ ] it up with him and did some toxic
[ __ ] [ __ ] that jade taught me i was just
[ __ ] girling around with her so he
taught me how like what the review press
process is like basically when you get
your instagram account shut down and
like which departments work on which
things
so basically told me that the integrity
department is the one that's up for
reviews right okay so i went on his
linkedin and i searched up um all of his
instagram connections and then i
searched up the ones in the integrity
department and then i messaged them on
linkedin to like why is she sharing them
back but obviously like they get all
those like so we're gonna take her
account so i they did it again yeah they
did it again
and then i contacted them on instagram
through my um like my backup but still
[ __ ] account
and i managed to find a couple not from
that department but like still people
that worked at instagram
in la and
everybody tagged mark zuckerberg in the
comments because this is important
information [ __ ] tag off the wall
street is she a porn chick no she's a
feminist
this is insane i better so i found a
couple to meet up with and
asian community is like pretty small in
l.a which is not true
yeah i was like what the hell it's small
podcast all i had to do was basically
reach out to them as like kitty likso
and we met up and like i [ __ ] a couple
of them and i was able to get my what is
she sharing all this for an order i love
her friend in the background the first
time basically what a friend looks
trippy trying to keep putting in reviews
and every time they put in another
review it gets sent to a different
person so as long as we'll pog
for you and that no jumper that's my guy
adam
yeah good guy
have someone really really like you
and like rally for you and you'll get
your account back girl power
well it's all about who you know right
yes
and what you do for them she goes and i
had sex with this guy so i know him now
what was her friend she said though
oh yeah i mean there you go who she
started sleeping with but i guess her
key her account gets taken down a lot so
she just creates you know another one a
lot of dicks
yeah you know how casually she's going
and there's a i [ __ ] a couple from
that department and then like she's just
so bad
now we know more about the ig review
process than we ever did that's actually
really good yeah so you just keep
putting the appeal in and you get
another another person another person
another person yeah we did learn
something from that every day okay thank
you chen you know what this girl's here
speaking of learning uh because i get
out of speaking of learning i will come
learn how to laugh in portland that is
june 9th through the 11th that is helium
portland nice june 9th through 11th san
francisco cobbs is june 17th through the
18th the trash panda summer tour
continues san diego july 21st through
the 23rd and then just added baltimore
august 4th through the 6th but also in i
think july is a new club in fort wayne
indiana that's where my uncle was born
oh foreign indiana yeah the creators of
uh tacoma comic club in bricktown yeah
oh adam norwood club yeah my boys be at
the west palm beach improv this friday
saturday sunday and then i got you tell
them why there's no final kid on monday
i'll be in i'll be traveling back yep so
we're gonna do it on tuesday yeah and in
richmond virginia funny bone you're up
june 3rd and 4th omaha nebraska funny
bone june 10 and 11. and then ontario
improv i'll see you june 30th july 1
july 2 in ontario california not canada
but california
nice i got uh
where it's jeffrey jefferson
it's uh
it's coming up you'll see you'll see
jeff die go to calendar count
left i should know these but i don't
have any memories uh colorado comedy
works it's going to be good june 7 june
4th then uh san diego i got uh mike drop
comedy club july 22nd 23rd august 5th
and 6th tampa florida side splitters uh
austin
that's a private thing and then i got
scottsdale arizona september 17th uh
actually don't come to that what are we
doing
i'm doing cb live in arizona coming up
soon oh perfect that's a great thing all
right kids love you jeff we love you the
best
dude yeah we'll have some fun tonight
the improv yes sir sold out kiddos all
right love you guys this fun kid we're
out